how's it go Bruce - so something really
strange happened yesterday I got an
email from Activision they were supposed
to send me an early copy of black ops 3
accidently they must have sent me the
wrong version and what they sent me was
black ops for retribution
you know everyone criticizes Call of did
for having a new game every year but
this is this is a new level like they
have the games ready
just making them and go out but yeah I
got it running here on my computer I
managed to get it to work through a
PlayStation 1 emulator and here we go
you
friendly rcxd inbound so in this Call of
Duty they're really up the story a lie I
assert is pretty epic wicked sick and
and the other games ready and this one
is it's really a new level of course
everyone wants to know about the actual
gameplay what's the new features of call
of duty black ops 4 so here we go it
includes so this calls it has a bunch of
celebrities in them uh last one had Cara
Delevingne this one has uh Justin
Bieber's dad alright so as you can see
right away we got free running in this
game you can roll which you can't do in
Call of Duty before it's they're really
taking the next level shoot fire is a
new feature as well uh this is [ __ ]
proper sick man holy [ __ ] you can fly
you can [ __ ] fly I gotta watch out
for the more goats popping advised
hostile I always wonder why there
weren't enough goats in the Call of Duty
bed great gameplay so far uh this game
really reminds me of Spira and if you
guys play that game a lot of
similarities uh another dragon huh ok
cool hellstorm missile in down and I'm
starving I I wish I could find some
Doritos in this game also you can you
can roll in this one and if I show that
you can roll a couple times it's pretty
pretty sick it's pretty wicked wicked
beast I'm really nervous I hope I hope
Activision is not gonna sue me for for
leak in their game that they send it to
oh god damn it [ __ ] me
you can die in the game that you can't
die it's confirmed confirmed here first
on the foot by channel um you can 360 in
this game I already feel like this is a
really good game like this is the first
good Call of Duty game I actually play
okay so dark holo is the new zombie mode
really excited to check out with this
one this can't play wait to play this
with my mates online on Xbox Live oh
dude the sound oh god there's zombies
everywhere they have shields now this
ambe's oh [ __ ] me met three more dragons
and then we can unlock multiplayer mode
so excited pure purple dragon awesome
game playing I could I could gameplay
all day honestly like if my mom did not
have a one hour limit a day I just I'd
still be playing right now [ __ ] double
kill [ __ ] Colette man awesome so
there's not many other weapons in the
game but I'm sure we'll all lock them if
we paid for that DLC you know since I
got it for free obviously I'm not gonna
get that so it makes sense to pay for it
okay so I'm gonna have to in that video
there I can't wait to play more of
Speyer Call of Duty just thank you for
watching let me know if you want to see
more Call of Duty gameplay on this
channel and I'll see you bros in next
one as always stay awesome breasts let's
do a Call of Duty that actually works
modern warfare 2 I love this game I have
over 900 hours of this game I'm sure
it's just as good as I remember it
alright alright alright
I'm [ __ ] pumped to play this [ __ ]
again